♪ ♪
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LET PARENTS
COME IN THE SCHOOLS AND ACTUALLY
TAKE BOOKS OUT AND MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS.
I DON'T THINK PARENTS SHOULD BE
TELLING SCHOOLS WHAT THEY SHOULD
TEACH.
>> Will: WE REMEMBER THAT
MOMENT, RIGHT, JUDGE?
WHEN THEY LOST THE VIRGINIA
GOVERNORSHIP THANKS TO THE
ARROGANCE, THEIR ARROGANCE ON
EDUCATION.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY HAVE NOT
LEARNED MUCH SINCE THEN,
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
ERIC SWALWELL THINKS IT STUPID
FOR REPUBLICANS TO PUT PARENTS
BACK IN CHARGE OF THEIR KIDS
LEARNING.
TWEETED THE FOLLOWING "PLEASE
TELL ME WHAT I AM MISSING HERE,
WHAT ARE WE DOING NEXT, PUTTING
PATIENCE IN CHARGE OF THEIR OWN
SURGERIES, CLIENTS IN CHARGE OF
THEIR OWN TRIALS, WHEN DID WE
STOP TRUSTING EXPERTS, THIS IS
SO STUPID."
A PRO PARENT GROUP TELLING FOX
"PRIORS LAMENT PARENTS ARE FIRED
UP AND WINNING AND BLUE STATES,
CONSERVATIVES FLIPPING SCHOOL
BOARDS IN NEARLY 40 CANDIDATES
BACKED BY PARENTAL RIGHTS GROUPS
WINNING 18 MINNESOTA.
WHAT IS ERIC SWALWELL MISSING?
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT DID YOU
SAY, WHEN WE STOP LISTENING TO
EXPERTS?
WHEN UCI SHOWED UP, THAT'S WHEN
WE STOPPED, PARENTS ARE THE ONES
WHO DECIDE WHERE THEY WANT TO
SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO SCHOOL,
WHAT THEY WANT THEM TO LEARN
COMING EVENTS IN THEM TO A
CATHOLIC SCHOOL, LUTHERAN
SCHOOL, CHARTER SCHOOL, JEWISH
SCHOOL, PUBLIC SCHOOL, YOU CAN
MOVE YOUR RESIDENCE TO PUT THEM
IN A DIFFERENT SCHOOL, I MEAN,
WE MAKE THESE DECISIONS BASED
UPON WHAT WE WANT OUR CHILDREN
TO LEARN.
AND WE WILL MOVE BECAUSE WE
DON'T LIKE THE WAY THAT THE
TEACHERS ARE TEACHING OR
TREATING OUR KIDS.
SO THE IDEA THAT THEY ARE IN
LOCAL APPRENTICE AND THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE GOING TO DECIDE
WHAT OUR KIDS LEARN IS ABSURD,
BECAUSE WE PAY TAXES THAT PAY
THEM AND PAY FOR THE SCHOOLS.
AND THEY ARE NOT GOING TO TELL
ANY PARENT, AND I DON'T CARE IF
YOU ARE IN A BLUE STATE OR RED
STATES COMING ASIDE IN THE
SELECTION, PARENTS ARE OUTRAGED.
IT'S LIKE MAMA BEAR CAME OUT AND
SAID DON'T YOU PLAY AROUND WITH
MY CUBS.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY -- IT'S ALL
ABOUT PARENTS BEING FIRED UP AND
IT IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
IT'S GOING TO CUT INTO THE
INDOCTRINATION THAT OUR CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN LEARNING AND OUR KIDS
ARE NOW THE HEADS OF
CORPORATIONS HAVE LEARNED FOR
DECADES THAT WE DID NOT KNOW
ABOUT AND NOW ARE SUFFERING
FROM.
THAT'S GOING TO STOP NOW.
>> Will: ROLLED, AND WILL
QUOTE YOU, YOU STOP ME AS I ASK
THE QUESTION TO DANA, HAROLD
SAYS HE DISTRUSTS PULLING, I
THINK THAT'S A FAIR SKEPTICISM,
ALSO THAT THE LEFT DOES NOT SEE
THAT THEY ARE EMBOLDENED BY THE
OUTCOME OF THESE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS, DO YOU THINK YOU
IGNORE THESE PARENTAL RIGHTS,
THESE ISSUES IF YOU ARE THE LEFT
AT YOUR OWN PERIL?
>> Dana: THEY WON'T BECAUSE
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF THINGS, ON
EDUCATION, THEY MIGHT TRY.
THE TEACHERS UNION IS VERY
POWERFUL.
BUT THEY KNOW NOW, WE ARE
WAITING FOR ARE SOME RESULTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK THOSE
SCHOOL BOARDS WILL FLIP AS WELL
TO REPUBLICANS, THERE IS ALSO
GOING TO BE HEARINGS AND THE
REASON THAT I DO THINK THEY ARE
PAYING ATTENTION A LITTLE BIT IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT
IT IN THE SHOW AND IT'S A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT SUBJECT, BUT
THE WHITE HOUSE DID TELL THE
HEAD OF THE CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL GUY THEY SAID, YOU NEED
TO RESIGN OR YOU WILL BE FIRED,
REFUSING TO RESIGN AND THEY WILL
FIRE HIM, BUT I THOUGHT THAT THE
BORDER WAS SO SECURE, WHAT IS
HIS NAME?
CHRIS MAGNESS, HE WAS FALLING
ASLEEP?
IN THE MEETINGS AND EVERYTHING,
TWEETING TO US DEATH TERRIBLY,
BUT SAID FOR MONTHS THAT
EVERYTHING WAS FINE AND THEN
THEY WERE FIRING HIM AND SAID
THAT EVERYTHING WAS OKAY TO
EDUCATION, IT'S CLEARLY NOT END
THE TASK FORCE PROVE THAT.
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
KNEW THAT THE STUDENT LOAN
BAILOUT WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
THEY DID IT ANYWAY.
IT WORKED FOR THEM.
THEY ARE PEOPLE THAT WERE LIKE,
GREAT, THIS IS GREAT.
AOC PRAISED HIM ONE SIDE UP AND
DOWN THE OTHER, IT WILL TURN OUT
TO BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL IN THE
SUPREME COURT WILL PUSH BACK,
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION LEAD
PEOPLE ALONG TO BELIEVE
SOMETHING EVEN THOUGH THEY KNEW
WHAT WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
ARE NEVER GOING TO GET IT DONE
JUST LIKE THEY DID WITH THE
EVICTION MORATORIUM.
>> Greg: YET, BEFORE I GET
INTO MY MAIN POINT I WANT TO
QUOTE WHAT HAROLD HAD SAID TO ME
IN THE GREEN ROOM WHICH IS HE
SUPPORTS ERIC SWALWELL, BECAUSE
"I HATE CHILDREN SO MUCH, THEY
MAKE ME SICK."
>> Harold: WE WILL HOLD ON
THAT.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHY THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO CEMENT
THEMSELVES AS A PARENTS PARTY,
LET THE DEMS BE THE PARTY OF THE
GOVERNMENT INTERFERENCE BETWEEN
MOTHER AND FATHER AND CHILD, LET
THEM DEFEND ACTIVISTS WHO PUSH
GENDER IDEOLOGY IN PRESCHOOL,
LET THEM BE AGAIN SCHOOL CHOICE
AND IN PERSON LEARNING,
REPUBLICANS SHOULD BE THE
PRO-FAMILY PARTY, BECAUSE IT IS
WORKING WHEN THE LEFT CALLS YOU
RACIST, WHAT DO YOU CALL THEM?
RUMORS, EVEN IF IT AIN'T TRUE,
BECAUSE A RACIST STUFF AIN'T
TRUE EITHER.
AND FINALLY, I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT WE HAVE TO REMIND
EVERYBODY THAT THE TEACHERS
UNIONS, THEY MAY BE THE MOST
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST ORGANIZATION
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE AGAINST
CHOICE.
BECAUSE THAT REALLY HURTS
MINORITY IS IT COMES TO HAVING A
COMPETENT EDUCATION THAT SETS
HIM UP HER LIFE.
>> Will: IS THIS AN ISSUE
WHERE YOU HOPE THAT THE LEFT
DOES NOT FEEL AFFIRMED OR
EMBOLDENED?
>> Harold: FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF THE STATEMENT OF THAT I
DISAGREE THAT PARENTS HAVE TO BE
INVOLVED, BUT WE HAVE TO LET
EDUCATORS DO THEIR JOB AS WELL
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE A HEALTHY
TENSION AND HEALTHY
RELATIONSHIP, TENSION MEANING IN
A CONSTRUCTIVE WAY BETWEEN
PARENTS AND TEACHERS,
REPUBLICANS NEED TO TAKE A
MESSAGE ALSO THAT ALL THE STUFF
THEY TALKED ABOUT WITH EDUCATION
DID NOT SEEM TO RESONATE EITHER
AT LEAST FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE
COUNTRY.
IF YOU LOOK FORWARD I DID, BUT
IN MICHIGAN, THE DIVORCE FAMILY,
THEY COMPETED IN ALMOST 200
SCHOOL BOARD SEATS AND ONLY WON
30.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN TO SAY THAT
EVERYTHING THEY ARE FOR I AM
AGAINST, BUT CLEARLY THEY DO NOT
COMMENCE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
MICHIGAN.
IT'S CALIFORNIA, MICHIGAN,
IDAHO, COLORADO, MINNESOTA, ALL
LED REFERENDUMS TO INCREASE
EDUCATION, SOME ARE
CONSERVATIVE, SOME ARE LIBERAL,
I DON'T KNOW ALL THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF HOW THOSE
WENT OVER OR HOW THEY CAMPAIGN,
BUT THEY PASSED.
VOTERS DON'T WHEN CULTURE WARS
IN THEIR CLASSROOMS.
THEY DON'T BOOK BANDS COME I
DON'T THINK THEY WANT DISHONEST
TEACHING AND THEY CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT THEIR KIDS TO BE
TAUGHT THAT THEY ARE BAD, BLACK,
WHITE, HISPANIC.
THERE'S A WAY TO DO THIS, GREAT
COMING MAKE A POINT I WILL GO AS
FAR AS THE RACIST POINT ABOUT
TEACHERS UNIONS, BUT I DO THINK
THOSE WHO PURPORT TO BE
ADVOCATES FOR KIDS, BLACK AND
BROWN IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
FAILING THEM AND HAVE FAILED
THEM LONG BEFORE COVID, THE
QUALITY OF EDUCATION THAT A LOT
OF THESE KIDS WERE HAVING SHOWN
WAS NOT THE QUALITY, DID NOT
MEET THE STANDARD THAT WE NEED
FOR THEM TO GET INTO COLLE